you know arm bring you bring up Coco
bear because that movie I already did
when did you guys watch it I watched it
on the plane there yeah and I downloaded
I'm like I don't know watch Mexican
cartoons you I stared at it for like 10
minutes there I go [ __ ] it and watch the
whole thing
they laughed there's some funny moments
in it but the end I don't know why but I
had snot bubbles of that no crying
it [ __ ] me up you know I like I was
doing the whole thing in there in there
people are like looking at me like I
somebody had died I mean I was I was
unconsolable I love that [ __ ] movie
how about you and that talk pilot is
here yes I've to everyone said they did
something yeah and my sister and I were
like in a in a deep embrace just sobbing
for - it's so touching it's one of the
you're actually one of the better
animated movies I've seen in a long time
I think if I didn't go to Tulum it
wouldn't affect me as my current would
cry but it kind of like reminded me of
it it's just a stray dog and I'm not
gonna get anyone spoiler do any spoilers
but you know and just you know that kind
of energy you know it kind of got that
right I mean I've been to Mexico Tijuana
Juarez yeah yeah
killing the game late night it was
killing it brat Adelita Chicago Club yum
yum Club those brothels are still around
I asked you walk around I asked around I
go is that elitist open oh yeah dude
yeah I ran into a guy who owns I'm not
gonna name his name but he owns a chain
of restaurants and he hasn't had a
girlfriend in like ten years and he
showed me photos oh here are my
girlfriends and he showed me photos of
women the really beautiful women and I
go oh was sort of like club you're a
part of or you know I'm some site or
like some dating app or you know these
are Adelita the girls of Adelita the
brothel I used to go to as a
and it's still there you know you got
ever like I know you love me I'm not
down I love you I know that we're the
one I don't doubt that I believe that's
why I don't go to a Lolita I know but as
a man because I think I do think that
monogamy in itself is sort of like is
this dated idea right I like to be
monogamous because I'm sort of a lazy
person I've been in a you know
polyamorous relationship before and it
was exhausting and that didn't work out
but as a man do you sometimes miss
inserting your penis into other you know
it's not that I think what it is is
there is as a kid because the I got
sober at 17 and then I started going to
brothels
so it's substituted that adrenaline rush
of drugs for me you know there's
something about crossing a border with
your friends with a lot of cash and
going to these brothels and you don't
know what's gonna happen you know and
you find somebody or you don't or
whatever but it's like it is a drug in
that way but that's the only thing that
but that's a young man's game I don't
need to do that and also to me that's
always a it's it's gonna help make me
relapse eventually if I behave in that
way
it's relapse behavior okay it's it's
dishonest it's it's also kind of like a
drug you know it's it's not reckless
it's risky I I'm not I you know you
think you know you think things through
as an adult you go if I do this right
this this this and this will happen
right and I don't you know I don't want
that I don't want to lose kalila I don't
want to lose my life I don't want to
lose you know so it's not in obviously
not even fathomable it's not worth it
and all in anyway so it's like you you
know you use you think it through but
you know you reminisce
about the old days I didn't think that's
healthy right yeah that's totally no I
think that everybody does that I know I
do that yeah you reminisce about I don't
reminisce about old boy having sex with
old boyfriends I reminisce about
randomly meeting people and then like
having like a full-on makeout session
and not knowing their name and then just
like going home and never seeing them
again that type of fun stuff where you
talk about you know the next morning
where you're having coffee with you know
your friends and you're like oh [ __ ] was
he even cute dude because I really I
mean I went slummin there are moments
where I'm just like they'll take
pictures tonight and I look at it the
next day I'm like oh my god I really
don't give a [ __ ] yeah